The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ERIK DEMAINE: All right,
today is our last lecture
on the predecessor problem.
And we did two lectures
on upper bound,
started with Van Emde
Boas x-Fast, y-Fast tries.
And then fusion
tries was last class.
This time, we're going to
show that those bounds are
essentially optimal.
And we're going to
prove this bound.
So we currently
have min of log w,
and log base w of n
as an upper bound.
That was Van Emde
Boas and fusion tires.
Were going to prove an
almost matching lower bound.
There's a log log w factor here.
And this bound holds for even
a static predecessor data
structure no updates, as
long as the data structure
has polynomial
space, which if you
have any hope of making
something dynamic,
you definitely want
polynomial space.
Now, it's known that this
log log factor is not real
if you have, essentially,
linear space or n log n space,
or something like that.
But that's much harder to prove.
So this is where we will end
our coverage of predecessor.
But I'm going to start out with
an overview of what's known.
And proving this lower bound
is actually pretty cool,
because at this point,
especially seeing fusion tries,
you might think bit tricks
are kind of all about magic,
and doing crazy
things, and using
these operations in bizarre
ways they weren't intended.
Bit tricks are necessary
as an upper bound tool,
given our weird
historical precedent,
which is computers are
built to do arithmetic.
And why not do bit
operations too?
And so it's sort of an
artifact of computers
as we know them today.
That's why we have the
word RAM, because it's
based on C, because it's based
on computers that exist now.
And that's legitimate in that
that's the computers we have.
So we might as well
try to use them.
The lower bounds, on the
other hand, are, in some ways,
more beautiful, because they're
just about how much information
has to go between Alice
and Bob, actually.
This is the communication
complexity perspective
of data structures.
And it's nice.
We will get, in some ways,
cleaner, simpler arguments
because in lower bound land, you
don't have to worry about, oh,
can I use this operation
or this operation to do?
It's just, is there any
operation at all to do it?
And then it's just
about information.
It's just about
information theory.
And it's, in some ways, cleaner.
And this proof, in
particular using a technique
called round elimination
is actually simple.
And we will see in it the
concepts of Van Emde Boas
and fusion tries again,
but without having
to do any bit tricks to
actually make them happen.
So if you felt like all of these
bit tricks are kind of weird,
what is the real
essence of the problem?
This, in some sense,
provides an answer.
And it says, well, really
those were the right answers.
That's what you should
have been getting.
So let me start with the survey.
This is more of a
historical survey.
So the first bound for
predecessor problem,
first lower bound,
Asvab Atjai in 1988.
And he proved that
for every word size,
there's a problem size such that
there is an omega square root
log w lower bound.
You can compare
that with this one.
This is log w over log log w.
Now, this is a bound that works
for all values of n and w,
which is more interesting.
Here, we're saying
that if you just
want a bound in terms of w, you
need at least square root log
w.
The original paper
claimed log w.
But that's not true, in general.
But the proof actually
establishes square root log w.
And in this proof
is complicated.
It was the first one.
It got the field started.
There's been many
papers since then.
Next one was by Miltersen,
who we've cited a few times.
And so this a few years later.
Miltersen, essentially,
took the same proof,
presented it in a
more coherent way,
and sort of really got to the
essence of what the proof was
showing, and could prove
the same bound, but also
a complementary
bound, because there
is a symmetry between word size
and problem size, which we will
see when we get to the
communication complexity
perspective, which will
be right after the survey.
It's not completely symmetric.
But Miltersen proved
this lower bound
that for every
problem size, there
is a machine, there
is a word size,
where you need omega
cube root of log n.
Now, we know how to get
order square root of log n
by taking them in.
So this is matching
up to the exponent.
And we know how to do
log w by Van Emde Boas.
So this is matching
up to the exponent.
So it's progress.
But it doesn't give a complete
picture of w versus n.
And this is the paper that
introduced this communication
complexity idea, that this
would be a useful concept
for predecessor lower bounds.
Then the following year,
there's a bit of a breakthrough.
So here, we've got the idea of
using communication complexity.
Then Miltersen and others had
the idea of round elimination.
And so just treat that
as a black box for now.
We'll explain what
is in a moment.
But it proved exactly the same
result, but in a clean way,
using round elimination.
These proofs were messy.
This proof is pretty simple.
And it's the beginning of
the proof that we will cover.
But we're going to prove
stronger bounds than this.
Let me go to another board.
Next, we have Beame and Fich.
Now is about the
time when I entered
the world of data structures.
And so Beame and Fich came out
just when I was starting, 1999.
And this proved for
all of w exists an n.
So log w over log log w,
which is the same thing we're
going to prove.
Except this only proves
it for certain values
of n, whereas we're going to
prove it for all values of n
where this is smaller than that.
So this is a bit more special,
not covering the whole w n
trade-off.
And then there's this
symmetric version.
There's going to be a
lot of log log n's today.
So get ready for
log logs in general.
So for every n,
there exists a w such
that there's an omega
root log n over log log n.
So this is almost matching
the min of fusion tries
and Van Emde Boas, which
is order square root log n.
They also proved-- did a little
bit on the upper bound side.
And they found a static
data structure achieving--
I'm just going to cheat
and use some arrows.
So they achieved the
min of these two.
So in a certain
sense, this is tight.
This is not exactly
what you'd want,
because the data
structures achieving
the min, what you'd like is
a lower bound of the min.
And it's not quite that.
It's saying, there's a
particular pair of w and n
values where this is optimal.
There's another pair
of n and w values
where this is
optimal with respect
to either one of
these parameters.
But there are other pairs
of values of w and n
where it may or
may not be optimal.
So it's kind of
matching, but not quite.
The way to say it is
these are the best--
this is the best pure w
bound you could hope for.
And this is the best pure n
bound that you could hope for.
And it's the best mix
of two pure bounds.
OK, then we go back in time
a little bit, which is--
there's a funny
chain here, which
is this paper, 1995, cites
this paper from 1999.
This paper cites
this paper of 1992.
That's normal.
This one's a little bit out
of order, bit of time travel.
So I think this one was
in draft for a long time,
and took awhile to finish it.
But this paper is before 1995.
It's not cited by this paper.
What's interesting
about it is it
proves both of
these lower bounds.
I don't think it proves
the upper bounds.
But these were independently
discovered by Beame and Fich
in the future of this paper.
This is actually a PhD thesis.
So I think it was lost, or not
known about, for a long time.
But it ends up establishing
the same bounds.
And then the real
contribution here
was that those were
the best bounds that
are purely w and n, but
still not a full story.
Next up is Sen in 2003, which
gave a round elimination
proof of the same result.
And whereas both the Beame
and Fich and the
Xiau proof are messy,
this round elimination proof
is very slick and clean.
And this is the proof
we're going to cover today.
And it's going to prove--
it will imply these pure
w and n lower bounds.
But it will, in some
sense, in a stronger way,
prove this bound, which
is a real min thing.
And so we're just off
by this log log factor.
Otherwise, we were proving
exactly the min of fusion tries
in Van Emde Boas is optimal.
Getting rid of the log
log factor is messier.
That's the next paper,
which is the last--
it's two papers, actually.
But the final
papers in this story
are by Patrascu and Thorup, 2006
and 2007 are the two papers.
And they give a tight n, versus
w, versus space trade-off.
I think I can fit
it on this board.
Let's try.
So it's the min of four terms.
The first term is
nice, log base w of n.
That's our good
friend fusion tries.
The next one is roughly log w.
So it's roughly Van Emde Boas.
But it turns out you
can do a little better.
Now, I need to define a.
I'm going to assume here the
space is n, times 2 to the a.
That's the notation they use.
It's a little bit weird.
But it makes this bound a
little bit easier to state.
So, of course, you need linear
space to store the data.
This is measuring words.
So the question is, how
much more than linear space
do you have?
If you want poly log update,
then this better be poly log n.
This is about static
data structures.
So if you want poly log n,
then a to be order log log n.
So you can think of a
being order log log n.
Or you can think of
a being constant,
if you want linear space.
Then this stuff--
I mean, then this
is basically log w.
OK, so that's roughly
Van Emde Boas.
Next, we get two crazier terms.
These ones, I can't give you
intuition for, I'm afraid.
You see, there's the log w.
They're, again, versions of
Van Emde Boas like things.
But they're improving by some
factors that make you better
when a is large.
And, in particular--
I mean, they should match
this thing at some points.
So when a is order
log n, that's when
you have polynomial
space, which would
be very difficult to update.
You need polynomial
time updates.
But that's what this
static data structure
uses polynomial space.
And so with polynomial space,
if you plug in a equals log n,
you end up improving
by a log log n factor.
And so that's where we are.
I guess there should be a
square root in there somewhere.
This is a log w over log log w.
This is the part that diverges
a little bit from Van Emde Boas.
And this really is achievable
if you have polynomial space,
instead of like n or n poly log.
So for static, yes, you can get
these log log n improvements.
We won't cover them here.
I mean, they're
small improvements.
And we're mostly interested
in dynamic data structures.
And for dynamic data
structures, these things
don't turn out to help.
So let me state the
consequence, which
is what I stated a
couple of classes ago.
If you have n poly
log n space, so if you
have polylogarithmic
update, which is usually
the situation we
care about, then we
get min of log base w of n.
And I'd like to say log
w, but you can actually
do slightly better.
Oh God, indeed.
I think I stated this
two lectures ago.
So log w is what
we know how to do.
This is a very
small improvement.
Let me state another
consequence of this,
which is Van Emde Boas is
optimal for w poly log n.
OK, that's when it gets
log log n performance.
And so you can
check in that case
this term doesn't
buy you anything.
That's log w would be order
log log n, if you're poly log.
So this disappears.
And you just get log w.
So that's one thing.
Fusion tries are optimal for
log w order square root log n,
times log log n.
So this is saying w is at
least 2 to the root log n,
or actually log n
to the root log n,
if you want to
include that term.
So that's a fairly large w.
So for large w, fusion
tires are optimal.
For small w, Van
Emde Boas is optimal.
In between, this
thing is optimal.
That's the reality of it.
It's a little messy.
But this is tight.
So this is the right answer.
I think most of the time, the
situations you care about,
w is probably going to be small.
So you should use Van Emde Boas.
If w really large, you
should use fusion tries.
In between, you could
consider this trade-off.
But it's not it's not much
better than Van Emde Boas.
So take that for what it is.
So that's what's known.
As I said, we're going
to cover this sen
proof, which will be tight
up to this log log factor.
And this holds as long as
your space is polynomial.
So it doesn't assume
very much about space.
And it's going to
be a lower bound
for a slightly easier problem.
If you can prove a lower
bound on an easier problem,
that implies a lower bound
on the harder problem.
The easier problem is called
the colored predecessor problem.
In colored predecessor,
each element is red or blue.
I should say blue, whatever,
anyway, no Team Fortress fans,
I guess.
So and now a query just reports
the color of the predecessor.
You don't need to
report the key value,
just whether it is red or blue.
So, again, you've
got your universe.
Some of the items are present.
And your query is an
arbitrary universe element.
And you want a predecessor
kind of this way.
And this guy is
either red or blue.
And you just want to
report which one is it?
So this is, of course,
easier, because you could just
have a lookup table, a
hash table for example,
that once you determine the
key, you could figure out
whether it's red or blue.
It's a static data structure.
So you could use
perfect hashing.
It could be totally
deterministic
once you set it up.
And so, OK, just reporting
the colors, of course
easier than reporting the key.
One interesting thing
about this problem
is it's very easy to get a
correct answer with probability
50%.
You flip a coin.
Heads is red, tails is blue.
And this lower bound
we proved will actually
apply to randomized
data structures that
work with some probability.
But it has to be probability
greater than half
of succeeding.
And this will be
useful, because we're
going to take our problem.
And we're going to
modify it a little bit,
and sort of make it
simpler and simpler.
And it's easier to preserve
this color property
than to preserve
actual key values.
So that's the
colored predecessor.
Now, we get to communication
complexity perspective.
So this is pretty cool.
And it brings us to the
idea of round elimination.
So communication--
OK, why don't I
tell you the generic
communication complexity
picture out of Alice and Bob?
And then I'll tell you how it
relates to data structures.
They're both simple.
But I've got to do
something first.
So let's say Alice is one
person who knows some value x.
Over here, we have Bob
who knows some value y.
The goal is to--
I'll move this a
little bit to the left.
Their collective goal--
they're trying to cooperate.
Their goal is to compute
some function of x and y.
The trouble is only Alice
knows x, and only Bob knows y.
So how did they do it?
They have to talk to each other.
Ideally, Alice sends Bob
x, or Bob sends Alice y.
One of them could compute
it, send back the answer.
That's one possibility.
But maybe x and y
are kind of big,
and you can't just
send it in one message.
So here's the restriction.
Alice can send messages with
less than or equal to little
a bits, a for Alice.
Bob can send messages with
less than or equal to little b
bits, b for Bob.
So that's the constraint.
And, potentially, x
is much larger than a,
and/or y is much longer than b.
And so you're going to have
to spend many messages.
And let's restrict to protocols
of the form Alice talks
to Bob, then Bob talks to Alice,
and back and forth, so rounds
of communication.
And you want to know,
how many rounds does it
take to compute f of xy?
And, of course, it depends on f.
OK, that's the totally
generic picture.
And there's
techniques which we're
going to use for lower
bounds on how long
these protocols have to be.
How does this relate
to colored predecessor?
And, remember, also there's
the model of computation,
which I should mention,
cell probe model.
Cell probe model, we just
count the number of--
in this case, because it's
a static data structure,
we don't really change it.
Let's say memory word reads.
We want to know how many
words of the data structure
do we need to read in order to
answer a colored predecessor
data structure?
If we can prove a
lower bound on this,
of course it applies lower
bound on the word RAM,
or pick your favorite model
that works with words,
transdichotomous RAM, whatever.
OK, so I want to cast
that cell probe picture
in terms of this picture.
So here's the idea.
Maybe I'll switch colors.
Alice is the--
I guess what do you
want to call it,
the algorithm, the
query algorithm.
OK, Alice is the poor
soul who has to compute
the color of a predecessor.
And so what's x? x is the query.
We're used to that.
That is the input
to the predecessor.
So it's a single word, which
is I want another predecessor
of some value.
Bob, on the other hand,
is the data structure.
That's the static thing.
Where Bob represents
the data structure,
y actually is the
data structure.
I guess if I want to be a little
bit more prosaic or something,
Bob you can think of as memory.
We'll call it RAM, to be a
little more space saving.
So Bob is the memory which you
can access in random access.
And what it knows is
the data structure.
I mean, that's
what it's storing.
That's all it's storing.
That's y.
Now, what are these rounds?
They are memory reads.
So what's a?
a is a log of the size
of the data structure,
because that's how many bits
you need in order to specify
which word you want to read.
So if you have, let's
say, s words of space,
a is going to be log s.
OK, you could make it larger.
But it doesn't help you.
So we're going to make
it as small as possible,
because that will
let us prove things.
It's fine to let a be
log s, because Bob is not
very intelligent.
Bob, you just say, look, I
would like word five please.
And it says, here's word five.
So it's not doing
any computation.
Alice can do lots of
computation and whatnot.
In fact, free computation,
we don't count that.
The question is
just, how many things
do you have to read from Bob?
Now, in this picture, Bob could
potentially compute stuff.
But we know, in
reality, it won't.
Lower bounds aren't
going to use that fact.
But that's why we can
set a to just be log s,
because Bob wouldn't do anything
with the extra information.
How big is b? b is just w,
because the response to a word
read is a word.
So this is the picture.
Query can probe
the data structure.
It says, give me word something,
which is only log s bits.
The response is w bits.
And you repeat this
process over and over.
And then, somehow, Alice
has to compute f of xy.
In this model, Bob doesn't
need to know the answer.
Of course, it's
just a single bit.
What is f of xy?
This is colored predecessor.
x is the query.
y is the data structure.
And f of xy, is it red or blue?
Is the predecessor
of x in this data
structure in the set
represented by this data
structure red or blue?
So it's one bit of information.
Alice could then
tell the bit to Bob.
But actually, in
this model, we just
want Alice to know the answer.
So if you can
prove a lower bound
on how many rounds of
communication you need,
then you prove a lower bound
on the number of memory reads.
Each round corresponds to
one word read from memory.
Clear?
So a very simple idea, but a
powerful one, as we will see,
because it lets us talk about
an idea which makes sense when
you're thinking about protocols
of rounds of communication,
but does not really make
sense from a data structure
perspective--
well, I mean, not as much sense.
Round elimination
is a concept that
makes sense for any
communication style protocol--
not just the red one, but
the generic white picture.
I need to define a little bit
before I can get to the claim.
This will seem weird and
arbitrary for a little while,
until I draw the red picture,
which is what it corresponds to
in the predecessor problem.
But just bear with
me for a minute.
Imagine this weird variation
on whatever problem
you're starting with.
So we have some problem
f, which happens
to be colored predecessor.
We're going to make a new
version of that problem, called
f to the k.
And here is the setup.
It's going to be a little
different from this,
and kind of fits
the same framework.
But now, Alice has k
inputs, x1, x2, up to xk.
Bob has y, as before.
And it has an integer, i,
which is between 1 and k.
Also, this is a technicality
because we'll need it
for colored predecessor--
we won't see that
for a few minutes.
But Bob happens to know all
the xi's up to xi minus 1.
And the goal is to
compute f of x i, y.
Maybe I should draw
a picture of this.
So we have Alice.
Alice has x1 up to xk.
Bob has y and i, same
communication setup.
And the goal is to
compute f of xi, y.
Before it was x, y.
And now, we're saying,
well, actually,
x consists of these k parts.
We really just care
about the i-th part.
So this function does
not depend on any other
of the xj's, just xi.
So naturally, Alice should just
communicate to Bob about xi.
Trouble is, Alice
doesn't know what i is.
Only Bob knows what i is.
So if you think about a
communication protocol,
where initially Alice sends
a message, then Bob responds,
that first message that Alice
sends is probably useless.
I mean, probably the first
question is, what's i?
That has no information.
It's just every time in the
beginning, you say, what's i?
Then Bob says, here's i.
And then after that one
round, Alice can you just
think about xi, from then on.
OK, one message may
seem like nothing.
But it's like every time
you put a penny in the jar.
After you do that enough
times, you have a lot of money.
So one message may
seem like very few.
But we just need to prove
a lower bound of log w
over log log w messages.
So you do this a few times.
Eventually, you'll get
rid of all the messages.
Now, if we can get rid
of all the messages,
it may seem crazy.
But it turns out you can iterate
this process of eliminating
that first message.
If we get rid of
all the messages,
the best we could hope
for is an algorithm
that is correct with
50% probability.
If Alice can do nothing,
then the best Alice could do
is flip a coin.
So we will get a
contradiction if we
get a zero message
protocol that wins
with more than 50% probability.
That's what we're
going to try to do.
But what does it mean to
eliminate this first message?
Let me formalize the
round elimination
a little bit over here.
So here's the round elimination.
This, again, works
for any function f.
So if there's a protocol
for this f to the k problem,
and Alice speaks first,
then that first message
is going to be roughly useless.
So let's suppose it has
error probability delta.
So there's some probability
it gives the wrong answer.
And let's suppose that
it uses m messages.
Then there exists a protocol
for f where Bob speaks first,
the error probability
goes up slightly.
And it uses one fewer message.
OK, ultimately, we
care about rounds,
which are pairs of messages.
But we're going
to count messages.
And then, of course, divide
by two, you get rounds.
So the idea is you can
eliminate the first message
that Alice sent.
The difference is, before you
were solving this f to the k
problem.
If you start with Bob, then
of course you know what i is.
And so then your
problem just reduces
to computing this f on xi, y.
So you don't get a protocol
for f to the k anymore.
But you get a protocol for f.
And we're going to
iterate this process,
and eventually eliminate
all the messages.
That's the plan.
Let me give you some intuition
for why this dilemma is true.
It's a little messy
for us to prove.
I'm not going to
give a proof here.
If there's time at the end,
I'll give a little bit more
of a proof.
But it will still use
some information theory
that we will not prove, and some
communication complexity which
we won't prove, because
it's a little bit involved
to prove this.
But once you have this
lemma, this lower bound
is actually quite easy,
and intuitive, and nice.
So that's where I
want to get to today.
But let's start
with some intuition
of why this should be true, why
there's this extra error term.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: Does it matter
who reports the answer?
Because there seems to
be some symmetry there.
ERIK DEMAINE: Right,
does it matter who
has the answer, Alice or Bob?
Let's just say you're
done when anyone
knows the answer,
either Alice or Bob.
Yeah, that would be cleaner.
Otherwise, you'd have to
send a message at the end
to tell it to
Alice or something.
So let's make it
symmetric, by saying
either Alice or Bob knows it.
Then the protocol can end.
Good question.
That way, we won't pay for
an additive one every time,
only pay for it at the end.
Good questions.
All right, so there's
an issue here.
It said, oh, Alice's
message is probably useless.
But maybe Alice gets
lucky, and sends xi.
Then, that message is useful.
What's the chance
that Alice sends xi?
Well, 1 out of k.
So there's something
going on there.
Alice doesn't just have to
send an entire xj, though.
Alice could send some
mix of these guys.
Maybe it sends the x
or of all the xj's.
Or it could be anything.
But there's a limit.
There's only a bits being
sent from Alice to Bob.
So the idea is if the
total number of bits
here is much bigger than a,
then very few of the bits
that you send are going to be
about a particular element xi,
in expectation.
So this is a
probabilistic thing.
So just imagine
this for the moment.
Basically, because we're
in lower bound world,
we get to, essentially, set
up the input however we want.
And so, in particular,
we're going
to prove a lower bound
that, in expectation--
so we're going to have a
probability distribution
of data structure, or
not data structures,
but of sets of values
that are in the set.
And the claim is that, in
expectation, any data structure
must do at least log
w over log log w,
minned with log base w of
n queries, in expectation.
So we get to assume that
the input is random.
And we'll see why in a bit.
So in this world,
we can assume that i
is chosen uniformly at random.
And given that assumption,
you would expect exactly a
over k bits to be about xi.
That would be the best
you could hope to do.
Sort of, you have a bits.
You spread them out
evenly talk about all
the xi's that you can.
So you get to communicate
a little bit of information
about the particular xi
that Bob will care about.
You don't know
which one that is.
So you have to communicate
about all of them.
So it's going to be a
over k in expectation.
So here's the idea.
We want to remove that message
so Alice can't communicate
those a over k bits.
So what's Bob going to do?
Bob is going to guess
them by flipping coins
so he gets them uniformly
randomly, a over k bits.
What's the probability
that Bob is right?
Well, it's going to be 1
over 2 to the a over k.
That seems not so big.
But if k-- how does it go?
If k is much larger than a, then
this is actually a good thing.
So let me-- so this was the
probability of being correct.
So the probability
of being incorrect
is going to be 1 minus that.
And we're interested in--
we had some probability
delta failing before.
And now there's this new
way that we can fail.
So I'm using union
bound here, saying,
well, we could fail the old
way, or fail the new way.
Maybe they're
correlated, maybe not.
But the worst cases
is that it wants
the sum of the two errors.
So the increase in error is,
at most, 1 minus this thing.
Now, this 1 minus 1 over
something to the power
or something, if this
something is large,
there's this fun fact 1
minus 1, over e to the x
is approximately x.
So this is going to be
approximately a over k,
if k is large enough.
So this is for large x--
small x, sorry.
k is large.
And so a over k is
small, very close to 0.
So if this were true,
then the error increase
would be order a over k.
There's e versus 2.
So there's a constant
factor I'm losing there.
It's not quite that good.
So this is only intuition.
The real bound has
a square route here.
And it's necessary.
And I don't have a great
intuition why it's square root.
It's just a little bit
worse than this intuition.
I mean, the main issue
is, what does it mean
for bits to be about something?
And can you really
just guess those bits?
Actually, you have to guess
the message that Bob sent.
So it's a little bit more
than just the bits that--
sorry that Alice sent.
So you lose a little bit more.
But it won't make a huge
difference to us, square root.
So that's some rough intuition
for round elimination.
Let's see why it is so cool
to have round elimination,
how it lets us prove
a pretty strong lower
bound on colored predecessor
in the cell pro model.
OK, I think I missed a
claimed somewhere here.
This is the lower bound
we're going to prove.
And it's nice and symmetric, log
base a of w, log base b of n.
This is kind of perfectly
symmetric in Alice and Bob.
Alice, well I don't
know which one
represents-- and, apparently,
Alice represents w.
Alice has got a bits to
communicate with to Bob.
I mean, the input, I
guess, is of size w.
That's the query.
Bob, on the other hand,
knows all the data.
So it's, in some sense,
represents the n side.
It's able to communicate
with b bits of information.
So log base b of n, somehow
enough to communicate n.
It's not a great
intuition for this.
But at least it's
nice and symmetric.
Now, let's work out what it
actually corresponds to for--
this is a lower bound
on colored predecessor.
So for any colored, even
static, colored predecessor data
structure, static
can be randomized.
And this will be a lower bound
on the expected performance.
OK, so what this implies
for polynomial space, which
is kind of the
case we care about,
for polynomial space
data structure,
a is going to be order log n.
In fact, we only need a
to be poly log n for what
I'm about to say to be true.
So then this becomes min log--
what n?
I guess.
Is that what I wrote over there?
I don't even remember.
I wrote a log log w.
I guess I'm going
to write log log n.
This is the right answer.
OK, fine, so we get a--
b is just w.
So that's a log base w of n.
That's just fusion tries.
This one, ideally,
would be log w.
But we're off by this log
log factor if a is log n.
That's the best we'll
be able to prove today.
So this is slightly
less beautiful,
because it's both w and n.
But so was this one.
And this is not the true answer.
The true answer has no log log.
But that's what we get
from nice symmetric bound
for polynomial space.
You can also use this
to prove the Beame Fich
lower bounds, which I've by now
erased, which are the pure--
the for all n, there exists a
w, for all w, there exists an n.
Why don't I briefly cover that?
Again, let's assume
that a is order log
n with polynomial space.
Then, the lower bound will
be largest when the two
terms in the min are equal.
So log base a of w
equals log base b of n.
And that's these two guys.
So this is log w over
a is order log n.
So this is going to
be order log log n.
And I want this to be
equal to log n over log w.
So we can cross multiply, get
log square w equals log n,
log log n.
And so log w is equal to
square root log n, log log n.
And let's see.
You can also take logs, and
from this conclude that log log
w equals log log n.
I'm throwing away
constant factors.
And when I say equal here, I
mean up to constant factors
for throughout this half board.
So you take logs.
You get 2 log log w
on the left hand side.
Over here, you get log
log n, plus log log log n.
So it's dominated by log log n.
So in this scenario, where these
two things are roughly equal,
you get log log w roughly
equal to log log n.
And so, from this bound,
or from this equality,
we should get the old
Beame Fich bounds,
which let me write them again.
So they are--
I mean, we want to compute
what was this bound.
We have log w, divided by log a,
or log w divided by log log n--
so log w, divided by log log n.
But log log n now is log log w.
So this is going to be log
w over log log w, which was
one of the Beam Fich bounds.
So for all w, there exists an
n, such that omega this thing
holds.
On the other hand,
we have log n,
divided by log w is now square
root of log n, log log n.
So this is log n, divided
by square root of log n,
log log n.
So the square root log
n cancels with this.
We end up with square
root of log n on the top.
And we keep the square root
of log log n on the bottom.
And so we get the other Beam
Fich Xiau bound, for all n,
there exists a w, such
that omega this holds.
And when you just
need existence,
then we get to choose the
relationship between n and w
however we want.
So you don't have to
believe me that it's
largest when they're equal.
It happens to be true.
But the point is, there
is a choice of w and n--
namely, this choice, log w
equals root log n, log log n,
where you get a
lower bound of this.
And there's another choice for
n versus w where this happens.
So this implies the
Beame Fich Xiau bounds.
But I kind of prefer this
form, because it's clear
up to this log log n
factor, we understand
the complete trade-off
between w and n,
assuming polynomial space.
So we're going to
prove this bound, which
implies all this stuff, using
round elimination lemma.
So we're proving
this claim here,
omega min log base of a
of w, log base b of n,
for any colored
predecessor data structure.
So let's suppose you have
a colored predecessor data
structure.
And it can answer
queries in t cell probes.
which in the communication
complexity perspective,
that's rounds of communication,
or colored predecessor.
Our goal is to do t
round eliminations.
Slight discrepancy
in terminology here--
round elimination
lemma is really
about eliminating one message,
which is half a round.
But you do it twice,
you eliminate a round.
And so we need to do two
t calls to this lemma.
We will eliminate all messages.
Then there's zero communication.
Then the best you could hope
to do is by flipping a coin.
Maybe you're worse than that.
But the probability of error
has to be at least 1/2.
So we'll either get
a contradiction.
Or we're going to set things up
so the error is, at most, 1/3.
And, therefore, this will
prove that t has to be large.
So you couldn't eliminate
all the messages.
Anyway, we'll see
that in a moment.
So we have a setup like this.
And in our case,
with this picture,
there is an asymmetry
between Alice and Bob.
I mean, yeah, the picture
is nice and clean.
But in reality, this has to
represent a colored predecessor
problem.
So in reality, Bob
is a data structure
and is not very smart,
just does random access.
Alice, we don't know,
could be very smart.
And Alice just
has a single word.
So there's an asymmetry
between Alice and Bob.
So when we eliminate a
message from Alice to Bob,
it's going to be
different from eliminating
a message from Bob to Alice.
This f to the k
thing here is going
to have to be
different when we're
doing an Alice to Bob message,
versus doing a Bob to Alice
message.
And that's where we're
going to get a min.
When we go from Alice to
Bob, we're going to be,
essentially, contributing
to this term.
When we go Bob to
Alice, we're going
to be contributing to this
term, I think, or the reverse.
We'll find out in a second.
So let's do first Alice
to Bob, because that's
the first type of message
we need to eliminate.
So let's suppose-- now, as
we eliminate things, w and n
are going to decrease.
So I'm going to
suppose at this point,
Alice's input has
w prime bits left.
Initially, w prime is w.
But I want to do the
generic case so I
don't have to repeat anything.
Here's the concept.
Remember, we're
proving a lower bound.
We get to set up the set of
elements however we want.
We're going to
define a distribution
on the set of elements.
And we're going to
do that by breaking
this input, w prime bits,
into a lot of pieces.
Alice's input,
you think of as x.
Don't necessarily
want to call it x.
Well, sure, we can call it x.
There it Is
What I'd like to do is break
that input into chunks, x1 up
to xk.
This is basically what
round elimination tells me
I should do.
If I want to view my problem
as an f to the k problem,
somehow my input is
not just one thing.
It's k things.
Well, in reality, the
input is a single word.
So I'm going to have to
split it into sub words,
in the usual way.
Van Emde Boas would
split it in half.
We're going to split
it into more pieces,
because we need to guarantee
that this error is small.
We need k to be large for
this error to be small.
I claim this is the
good choice of k.
And so now, this is x1,
this is x 2x, this is xk.
The low order bits are xk.
The high order bits aer x1.
Or the reverse, it
doesn't actually matter.
So why is this a
good choice of k?
Because if we then look
at the error increase
we get from here,
error increase is
square root of a divided by k.
So error increase,
which is order a over k,
is going to be k is now this.
So the a's cancel--
sorry, square root of a over k.
A over k was the wrong analysis.
The square root of a over
k is the correct bound.
Still, the a's cancel,
because the k has an a factor.
And so we get order
square root of 1
over t squared, also
known as 1 over t.
This is good.
There's a constant here.
And if I tune this
constant correct,
I can make this
constant less than 1/3.
So if I start with a
protocol, let's say,
that's completely correct--
you don't have to.
You could start with one
that's correct with at least
probability 3/4 or something.
But let's just say, for
simplicity, the initial data
structure is completely correct.
If every time I do an
elimination of a message,
I guess I should set it
to be 1/6 time's 1 over t,
and I do this 2 times
t times, in the end
the error will be only 1/3.
So I'll be correct
with 2/3 probability.
So never mind the constants.
I can set this constant right
so this is some epsilon times 1
over t.
So after I do this 2 t
times, I end up with an error
that's only epsilon, or
2 epsilon, or whatever.
So that would be
a contradiction.
So that's why this
is a good choice.
I'm basically balancing the
error I get from every message
elimination.
I want them all to
be order 1 over t
so it's nice and balanced.
That will give me the best
lower bound, it turns out.
But what does this mean?
I mean, somehow I have to have
an f to the k problem, meaning,
really I should
only care about 1xi
here, that all the interesting
stuff is these bits.
But Alice doesn't
know which is i.
Only Bob knows which is i.
What does that mean?
Bob knows the set of elements
in the data structure.
So, basically, the
set of elements--
maybe they all
differ in these bits.
Or maybe they all differ in
these bits, or these bits,
or these bits, but
only one of these.
So that's a
distribution of inputs.
There's one class of
inputs where they all
differ in the x1 part.
But then they're
identical for the rest.
For each xi, there's
a set of inputs
where they all differ in
the xi's, and nowhere else,
let's say.
But Alice doesn't know
which setting she is in.
Alice just knows x.
And so Alice is
kind of in trouble,
because you can only
send a few bits.
You can only send a
bits out of this thing.
So you can't
communicate very much.
Let's go over here.
I need the bound.
I don't need the corollary.
Let me draw a picture
for Alice, or for what
the data looks like.
So there's some
initial segment, which
is shared by all elements.
Then they all differ
in this middle chunk.
And then they all have--
I don't really care what
they have after that.
So these are the elements
in the data structure.
And this is our usual
picture of a binary tree.
Except, I didn't draw it binary.
I drew it with some
branching factor
so that the height of this
tree is theta at squared.
So I set the base
of my representation
so that you branch whatever,
w divided by at squared here.
That's my branching factor.
So cool, that's my picture.
And this is depth i.
So Bob knows this picture.
Bob knows what all the
elements are so it can
build this picture or whatever.
Bob knows which is the relevant
depth that they differ.
But in the lower
bound, we're going
to say a is chosen
uniformly at random.
So Alice has no idea
which bits to send.
And so probably, Alice is
going to say, oh, here,
I know these bits.
But Bob already knew those bits.
So Bob learned nothing.
And so that's why you
can eliminate the round.
That's the intuition, anyway.
The proof is, well, you just
apply round elimination.
You see that the problem now
becomes to compute predecessor
on this node.
Just like in fusion tries,
at every step of the way,
the hard part was to compute
predecessor at the node.
Here, if Bob is allowed
to do computation,
then, really, Alice
just needs to say,
what are the things here?
Or together, Alice
and Bob somehow
have to figure out, what is the
predecessor at this node of xi?
Which way the query
goes, which could
be in between one of
these, that is xi.
The rest of the
xj's don't matter.
Only xi matters.
And so the problem reduces to
computing predecessor here.
And that matches the
definition of f to the k.
So we have successfully set
up an f to the k problem.
The only thing you need to do
to solve the overall predecessor
problem is to find your
predecessor in the node,
because there's only one element
within each subtree that's
enough to figure out
your overall predecessor.
OK, depth i, at squared, I guess
you can think of this as y.
That's the part that Bob knows.
These are, in some sense,
xi up to xk minus 1.
And this is why we had to say
over here that Bob already
knew xi up to xi minus
1, because Bob already
knows that the shared
prefix among all the items--
sorry, not minus 1, i minus i.
And so all the content is
here in this node, which is y.
And so it reduces to a regular
predecessor problem, which
is what f will always denote,
colored predecessor of xi, y.
Cool.
OK, what happens here
in terms of n and w?
We have a smaller problem here.
We threw away all this stuff.
What got reduced is
our word size for here.
We started with something
of size w prime.
And now, we end
up with something
of this size, which
was W prime divided
by at squared up to theta.
So this reduction reduces--
or this round elimination
reduces w prime
to w prime, divided by
at squared, theta that.
I think that's all I need
to say at this point.
The claim is that this picture
is kind of like Van Emde
Boas in the following sense.
Van Emde Boas is,
essentially, binary
searching on which
level matters.
If it goes too low,
things are empty.
If it goes too high,
there's too many items.
So it's binary searching
for that critical point,
where you basically have
a node and nothing else.
And that's why it took log w.
So here, one level matters.
And the goal is to
figure out which one.
And it's not exactly
binary search here.
We're losing a larger factor,
at squared, at each step.
So we're not reducing
w to w over 2,
like we did with Van Emde Boas.
But this is why we're
losing a little bit.
We reduce by a
factor of at squared.
So it's kind of like the
Van Emde Boas upper bound.
But here, we're setting up a
lower bound picture so that--
this is still an arbitrary
predecessor problem.
But figuring out which level
matters, that's tricky.
And you really
can't do much better
than Van Emde Boas to
style a binary search.
OK, maybe you can do at
squared wave binary search,
instead of binary search.
So that was eliminating a
message from Alice to Bob.
Eliminating a message
from Bob to Alice
is going to look
like fusion trees.
That's the cool thing.
So let's do that.
Next page.
OK, let's suppose--
so this is going
to get slightly confusing
notationally, because you
have to reverse a and b.
The picture I set up over here,
and for the round elimination
lamma f to the k, and
round elimination lamma,
are all phrased in
terms of eliminating
the Alice to Bob message.
You've got to invert everything.
So we're going to get square
root of b over k error
if I don't relabel things.
So you can restate this,
if Bob speaks first,
and then Alice
speaks next, I get
square root of b over k error.
The F to the k problem is
now that Bob has k inputs.
Maybe call them y1 to yk.
Alice has an input
x and the integer i.
So now Alice, the
querier, knows what i is.
But Bob doesn't.
The data structure
doesn't know it.
So it just reversed everything.
So let me state it over here.
Bob has input.
Now, in general, what Bob
knows is a bunch of integers,
n integers.
In general, n prime
integers, because n
is also going to increase.
And let's say each of
them is w prime bits.
That's what Bob knows.
That's y.
So what do we have to do to
phrase an f to the k problem?
Well, just like this, we've
got to break that input into bt
squared equal-sized chunks.
So let's just think
about what that means.
So it's going to be y1 up to yk.
k is theta bt squared.
Again, we want bt
squared, because then you
plug it into this
root b over k formula.
And you get that
the error increase
is order 1 over t,
which is what we need
to do t round eliminations.
So before, our input
was a single word.
Now, our input is a
whole bunch of integers.
So it's natural to split it
up into different integers.
Here's how I'm going to do that.
I'll just draw the
picture over here.
So this was the Alice
to Bob elimination.
Now, we'll do the
Bob to Alice picture.
So what I'd like to do is
split up all the inputs.
What's the natural
way to do that?
Well, have a tree at the top.
Let's just make
it a binary tree.
So I'm drawing the usual
picture I draw when
I draw a bunch of elements.
And then there's some
elements left over
in each of these subtrees.
Each of these is a
predecessor problem.
I'm constraining the
inputs to sort of differ
a lot in the beginning,
in the early bits,
the most significant bits.
This is the most significant,
next most significant,
and so on, bits.
I want the number of leaves
here to be theta bt squared--
or not leaves, but number
of intermediate nodes here.
And, therefore, there are
theta bt squared subtrees.
And I want to set up the n items
to be uniformly distributed.
So each of these has n
divided by bt squared items.
So we used a few
bits up top here.
How many bits was this,
just log of bt squared?
So if you look at one
of these subproblems,
we have reduced w slightly, but
only by this additive amount.
It basically won't matter.
The big thing we
changed is we used
to have n items to search among,
or this is n prime, I guess.
Now, we have and divided
by bt squared items.
So we reduced n substantially.
And this is what
fusion trees do, right?
They look at the root
first, and say, OK, look, I
can distinguish w to the
epsilon, different things
in constant time.
Here, it's on w to the epsilon.
But it's b to bt squared.
And we haven't figured
out what bt are yet.
I mean, b is w.
So that's close to a w
factor, w folds search.
And then you determine, am I in
this subtree, or this subtree?
This is exactly what
fusion trees do.
But we're setting up
a lower bound instance
where that is the
right thing to do,
where you have to know
what the early bits are
before you can figure out
which subtree you're in.
Now, reverse roles.
Alice knows what these bits are.
The data structure
of relevance--
let's suppose you fit
here, because you are 0111
in the beginning.
This is our yi problem.
Alice knows what i is.
Alice knows what those
leading bits are.
Bob doesn't.
And Bob is speaking first.
So Bob could try to summarize
this entire data structure.
But there's basically no hope.
Bob needs to know, what
are those early bits?
So the first message from
Bob is going to be useless.
Alice can then send the bits.
And then you can
restrict your problem
to a regular predecessor
problem in here.
And so you've eliminated
this sort of root node.
Your entire problem is a
predecessor problem in here.
So, again, we have an f
to the k style problem.
We reduce to a predecessor
problem on a smaller--
in this case, y
and x are reversed.
But we end up with
a smaller problem,
mainly in the fact
that n got smaller.
So let me go back to this board.
What happens is that
we reduce n prime
to n prime, divided
by bt squared.
There's theta.
We also reduce w prime.
w prime becomes w prime,
minus log bt squared.
OK, but in particular,
this is going
to be at least w prime
over 2 most of the time,
till the very end.
And over here, we're reducing
w prime by a big factor,
something bigger
than a constant.
So we don't really care
about losing a factor of 2,
because we alternate
between these.
And so a factor of 2 just
falls into the theta.
So it's going to be at least
that, as long as w prime is,
I don't know, at least log--
log w would be enough.
Yeah, this is log w.
t squared is going to
be, at most, log w.
So this is going to be
log w, plus log log w.
Log log w goes away.
What is t?
The whole point is to
prove a lower bound on t.
But we know from an
upper bound perspective,
t is, at most, log w,
because Van Emde Boas exists.
So we're never going to prove a
lower bound bigger than log w.
So whatever t is going
to be is, at most, log w.
So this is just log w.
So you're fine.
But at some point,
we have to stop.
We start with some w and n.
n prime is racing
down at this rate.
w prime is racing
When w prime gets down to
log w, then we're in trouble.
If n prime gets down to 2,
1, 0, one of those constants,
when n prime gets down to a
constant, we're in trouble.
You can no longer
evenly divide things.
So when does that happen?
This is where we're going
to get a lower bound.
So I guess we can
go back over here.
So if you do a
round elimination,
you decrease w prime
by this factor.
And you decrease n
prime by this factor,
both of these in sequence.
Then you repeat it.
So we have to stop when
w prime hits log w,
or when n prime
hits 2, let's say.
This is not really going
to make a difference.
You can also think that as 2.
So, in fact, I'll just
do that, just to clean
the arithmetic a little bit.
Now, if we succeed in
eliminating all the messages,
we get a contradiction,
because we set up our errors
to add up to only 1/3.
And we know the error
has to be at least 1/2,
if you eliminate all the
messages, which means we didn't
eliminate all the messages.
Now, we will not eliminate all
the messages if t is large.
So when would we eliminate
all the messages?
Let's compute that.
And then t has to be
at least that big.
t has to be greater than
the point at which we would
eliminate all the messages.
Otherwise, we would
get a contradiction.
So this is where we get a
min, which is kind of cool,
because we have to stop
when w prime gets too small,
or when n prime gets too
small, whichever happens first.
And so it's going to be a
min of the thing relating
to w, which is going to be
log base at squared of w,
because we're reducing w
by a factor of at squared
in each step.
So that's when it's
going to bottom out.
And then there's the
thing for n, which
is log base bt squared of n.
That's when n will
bottom out, because we're
reducing by a factor of
bt square at each step.
So that's the bound we get.
Now, it doesn't look quite
like the bound that we want,
which is this very simple log,
base of w, log base b of n.
But I claim that it's
basically the same thing.
Why?
I got to cheat here, speed
things up a little bit.
I claim that at squared
is order a cubed.
Why?
Because a is at least log n.
Remember, a is log of space.
You have to store the data.
So you need at least
n words of space.
a is log of that.
So it's got to be
at least log n.
And, furthermore,
t is at most log n.
Why?
Because there is a predecessor
or data structure that
runs in log n time
operation, namely
balance binary search trees.
There's a theta here,
order, big O. But at squared
is, at most, a cubed.
On the other hand, this thing,
bt square, is order b cubed.
Why?
Because t is order
log w. b is w.
That's the definition of b.
T is order log w, because
Van Emde Boas exists.
And so this is actually, at
most, w times log squared w.
But, in particular,
it's at most w cubed,
because we don't care about that
constant because it's in a log.
So it just comes out.
It's a factor of
1/3 or whatever.
And so this is the same
thing as log base a of w,
log base b of n, minned.
And that's the nice,
symmetric bound
that you get our of round
elimination, pretty cool.
Now, if you look
in the notes, I'll
just mentioned this
briefly, there's
a couple of more pages that
give you a little bit of flavor
of what the round elimination
and that vague proof sketch,
which gave the wrong answer by
a square root, really means.
We said, oh, Alice
can only communicate,
in some sense, a
over k bits about xi.
And you can formalize that by
talking about distributions
of inputs, and talking about
the expected amount of entropy
of xi communicated by
that first message.
And so it's very simple
definitions of entropy,
and shared information,
but just in terms
of probabilistic quantities.
And it at least
gives you a sense
of how you might prove
something like this.
Whereas talking about
information about something
is kind of vague,
talking about entropy,
which is about sum
of probabilities
times log of probabilities is
a clean, probabilistic notion.
So it becomes a purely
probabilistic statements
about error probabilities.
And that's how you argue this.
But even these notes
do not give a proof.
They just give a hint of how
you formalize what this means,
or what the proof sketch means.
And it's several pages
to actually prove it,
so a bit beyond this class.
But once you have it--
because it's very clean,
I'd say kind of beautiful
lower bound, not quite
the right answer, but
up to log log factors,
the right answer
for predecessor.
So that's the end of
predecessor in this class.